yeah
[Music]
the statements
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
specific ways sure when motion my Chitra
would attack a penny when I was REME
explain president mega spider pig over
as president I'm seein a starter family
ki bang on the drum pump rashly but
cryin need elevate must fear should I
especially me if Ali's name materially
Jewish sustain a perspective resist and
Rakowski cut machine clicks you with a
process nuna Rodney famous kidney
geometry witness to a booster Union
National is worth solution appealed at
NACA the truth mr. LaRouche race and
oppression atmosphere a new objective
pitching how would never at the quenches
if Papa Ostrava ideologies cooperate
Western Australia the look of Roslin AB
some of camellia Cardinal is minnows she
would erase EE
Sasha stalker with the solution image
visible a personal response York a
mechanism of which not only Bishop as
nesting
stability Regan and necrosis a españa
gross terrorism a trance
granny Schnee to the chronology Utley
neurasthenia problem of marijuana mikky
ekko like is key
Doogie risky private source of GMOs
natalka
a visionary silly Naidu to me Rajani
mono-ethnic ask my partner
see witness need to recover at
resilience earnestness president on
[ __ ] Uncle Vanya will provide negative
initial thoughts over booster
- a limited period shaggy boy as
traveling west on Avellino premium limo
Lavinia de year it was Recio Prius near
Union Park Singapore simple installation
was a limited group initially - a mini
film asobu at guest list the Muse Luna
Rodney B services should I avoid nam mo
governor bottom athletic girl look for
programmatic strategies new perfume
approximate stabilization was a serious
cognition a Java magnesium asobu
activist ernest the muse new narrow
bridges our fastest version in the very
bottom at least Renea
seriatim can't leave me breathless rainy
night at the Kimo
mr. team near pidemo Delhi Nisha fermion
Roboto Roboto complex when apologist
orange toward Asia to the prodigious to
the governor of Virginia a person I
thought of a chorus vision element of
globulin system mysterious neighbor on
opening at the gabiru liquid at Sarah
keahi initial dynasty each magical
machine of course basic genius at the
very base theorem in Augustine keep the
Virginia at this particular post
he admitted to nauseous pitiable dude
Robert with a small solution some is
very premium it is negatively of the
Magisters group we Americans live
acoustic apostasy of Lanka they worship
show cetera where I see it should be a
not a mere four football rupture contact
Linnaeus peaceful valley as my PhD night
system more resilient roasted lasagna
was the trouble group of anteater or oh
no guerrilla resistance of father no
postures exactly
let's give the usual interests about we
have two little points of contact and
interact close already and a variety of
interim international for clearly we
mentioned the original sizes for
instance Syria task of establishing
peace and reconciliation in this country
could be the first showcase example of
the successful joint work
Russia and the United States take
leadership in this issue and organize
the interaction through humanitarian
crisis and help Syrian refugees to go
back to their homes in order to
accomplish this level of successful
cooperation in Syria we have all the
required components but remind you that
both Russian and American military
required as useful experience of
coordination of their action established
the operational channels of
communication through which we needed to
avoid dangerous incidents and
unintentional collisions in the air near
the ground also terrorists Southwest
this is south of Syria compliance with
the Treaty of 1974 about the suppression
of forces about suppression of forces of
Israel and Syria
this will bring peace to
probably newsstand villainess review
lasting in compliance with the
respective resolutions Security Council
for instance the resolution three three
eight we're glad that the Korean
Peninsula issues to resolve it was very
great extent it was possible thanks to
the personal engagement of President
Trump who prefer opted for dialogue
instead of confrontation we also
mentioned the United States from the
Iranian nuclear deal country control of
IAEA effectively ensures the exclusively
peaceful nature of Iranian program
strengthens the conscious realization
fulfillment means the United States
could be more determined in insisting on
it and well in influence the Ukrainian
government to work in that direction a
special attention was paid to the
economy the interest in cooperation on
from the business circles is certainly
president the American business
delegation was one of the largest in
only at the May Petersburg st.
Petersburg Economic Forum over 600 or
500 representatives American business
circles to contribute to development of
trade investment
mr. Trump and I have agreed to create a
high-level group to unite the captains
of Russian and American business the end
entrepreneurs know it better how to
build mutually lucrative cooperation let
them think what can be done and let them
come up with their own proposals
president Trump again touched upon the
subject of the so-called Russian
interference in the electoral campaign
of the United States I had to repeat
what I've said before including at
personal meetings with mr. Trump that
Russian government has never interfered
is not going to interfere in the
American domestic affairs including
their electoral process if any such
evidence is provided we're ready to
examine it as part of the work group for
cybersecurity which we discussed with
mr. Trump at previous meetings and
obviously it's high time he fries Hush a
Russian American connections in public
organizations and cultural and
humanitarian areas you know there
recently were visited by a delegation of
American congressmen and it's been
perceived as nearly a historic event
while in fact it must be a routine
routine visit a routine action
so we I've asked mr. president to think
not only about practical matters but the
philosophy of building relations for a
long-term perspective it would be useful
to involve the experience of experts who
know history well and specifics of
Russian in American interaction via the
idea is to create an expert Union from
influential and Russian and American
political scientists ex diplomats and
military people who would start to find
common grounds and thinking about how we
can bring our cooperation into a stable
and positive condition on the whole we
are contempt with the results of our
meeting previously we are only briefly
met at international fora we had a good
talk with mr. prompt and hopefully we
now understand each other better I am
thankful for that too mr. Trump - Donald
of course many problems remain and we
failed to clear all all obstacles it was
impossible to do it at the first meeting
but I think we made an important first
step in that direction to conclude I
would like to mention that creating a
working atmosphere is to a great extent
the merit of our Finnish hosts we're
very grand grateful to the Finnish
government Finnish people and residents
of Helsinki for what they have done I
know we've caused a lot of inconvenience
to them and apologized to that thank you
very much thank you I have just
concluded a meeting with President Putin
a wide range of critical issues for both
of our countries
we had direct open deeply productive
dialogue went very well before I begin I
want to thank president nini Stowe of
Finland for graciously hosting today's
summit President Putin I was saying how
lovely it was and what a great job they
did I also want to congratulate Russia
and President Putin for having done such
an excellent job in hosting the World
Cup it was really one of the best ever
and your team also did very well
it was a great job I'm here today to
continue the proud tradition of bold
American diplomacy from the earliest
days of our republic American leaders
have understood that diplomacy and
engagement is preferable to conflict and
hostility a productive dialogue is not
only good for the United States and good
for Russia but it is good for the world
the disagreements between our two
countries are well known and President
Putin and I discussed them at the length
today but if we're going to solve many
of the problems facing our world then
we're going to have to find ways to
cooperate in pursuit of shared interests
too often in both recent past and long
ago we have seen the consequences when
diplomacy is left on the table we have
also seen the benefits of cooperation in
the last century our nations fought
alongside one another in the Second
World War even during the tensions of
the Cold War when the world looked much
different than it does today the United
States and Russia were able to maintain
a strong dialogue but our relationship
has never been worse than it is now
however that changed as of about four
hours ago I really believed that nothing
would be easier politically than to
refuse to meet to refused to engage but
that would not accomplish anything as
president I cannot make decisions on
foreign policy in a futile effort to
appease partisan critics or the media or
Democrats who want to do nothing but
resist obstruct constructive dialogue
between the United States and Russia
affords the opportunity to open new
pathways toward peace and stability in
our world I would rather take a
political risk in pursuit of peace than
to risk peace in pursuit of politics as
president I will always put what is best
for America and what is best for the
American people during today's meeting I
address directly with President Putin
the issue of Russian interference in our
elections I felt this was a message best
delivered in Paris
spend a great deal of time talking about
it and President Putin may very well
want to address it and very strongly
because he feels very strongly about it
and he has an interesting idea
we also discussed one of the most
critical challenges facing humanity
nuclear proliferation I provided an
update on my meeting last month with
chairman Kim
and that problem going to work with us
and I appreciate that commitment the
president and I also discussed the
scourge of radical Islamic terrorism
both Russia and the United States has
suffered horrific terrorist attacks and
we have agreed to maintain open
communication between our security
agencies to protect our citizens from
this global menace last year we told
Russia about a planned attack in st.
Petersburg and they were able to stop it
cold they found them they stopped them
there was no doubt about it I appreciate
it president Putin's phone call
afterwards to thank me
I also emphasized the importance of
placing pressure on Iran to halt its
nuclear ambitions and to stop its
campaign of violence throughout the area
throughout the Middle East as we
discussed at length the crisis in Syria
is a complex one cooperation between our
two countries has the potential to save
hundreds of thousands of lives
I also made clear that the United States
will not allow Iran to benefit from our
successful campaign against Isis we have
just about eradicated Isis in the area
we also agreed that representatives from
our national security councils will meet
to follow up on all of the issues we
address today and to continue the
progress we have started right here in
Helsinki today's meeting is only the
beginning of a longer process but we
have taken the first steps toward a
brighter future and one with a strong
dialogue and a lot of thought our
expectations are grounded in realism but
our hopes are grounded in America's
desire for friendship cooperation and
peace and I think I can speak on behalf
of Russia when I say that also
President Putin I want to thank you
again for joining me for these important
discussions and for advancing open
dialogue between Russia and the United
States our meeting carries on a long
tradition of diplomacy between Russia
the United States for the greater good
of all and this was a very constructive
day this was a very constructive few
hours we spent together it's in the
interest of both of our countries to
continue our conversation and we have
agreed to do so I'm sure we'll be
meeting again in the future often and
hopefully we will solve every one of the
problems that we discussed today so
again President Putin thank you very
much smoke that they put his key
Americans can manage a net rescue of
criminals introduce yourself my name is
alexey muzhikov
I represent the Interfax information
agency my question is to mr. Trump
during your recent European tuna tour
you said that implementation of the
pipeline project dream makes Europe
hostage to Russia and you suggested that
a Europe gets rid of that dependence by
delivering American liquefied gas but
this cold winter show the viability of
the existing system of algebra in Europe
while the united states have to would
have to buy extra volumes of liquefied
gas so the implementation of your idea
is more political and economic and won't
it cause a situation when the energy
supply in Europe will create a hole to
which the consumer countries will get
first of all and
second question if you permit me before
meeting President Putin you called him
here arrival but left a hope that you
will probably make that's the
relationship friendly one did you manage
thank you and a good competitor he is
and I think the word competitor is a
compliment I think that we will be
competing when you talk about the
pipeline I'm not sure necessarily that
it's in the best interests of Germany or
not but that was a decision that they
made we'll be competing as you know the
United States is now or soon will be but
I think it actually is right now the
largest in the oil and gas world so
we're gonna be selling LNG and we'll
have to be competing with the pipeline
and I think we'll compete successfully
although there is a little advantage
locationally so I just wish them luck I
mean I did I discussed with Angela
Merkel in pretty strong tones but I also
know where they're all coming from and
they have a very close source so we'll
see how that all works out but we have
lots of sources now and the United
States is much different than it was a
number of years ago when we weren't able
to extract what we can extract today so
today we're number one in the world at
that and I think we'll be out there
competing very strongly thank you very
much a couple of words we spoke on that
subject also we know the mr. president's
position but I believe all and gas power
the United States are also that country
a woods could work constructively in
regulating international markets because
we're not interested in drastic full of
prices beyond the threshold because that
will make our producers suffer including
the United States with their shale gas
and oil
beyond certain limits the profitability
of production disappears but we are
neither interested in extremely high
prices but that will kill machine
building and other branches of economy
we have something to discuss here and
have a field for collaboration that's
one thing the second thing regarding
northern stream to a mr. president's
what is his preoccupation about possible
disappearance of transit through Ukraine
and I assured mr. president Russia is
ready to preserve that transit moreover
we are ready to extend the transit
contract which expires next year if the
dispute is settled between in the
Stockholm arbitration court the first
question from a u.s. journalist goes to
Jeff Mason from Reuters Thank You mr.
president you tweeted this morning that
it's us foolishness stupidity and the
Muller probe that is responsible for the
decline in US relations with Russia do
you hold Russia at all accountable for
anything in particular
and if so what would you what would you
consider them that they are responsible
for yes I do I hold both countries
responsible I think that the United
States has been foolish I think we've
all been foolish we should I had this
dialogue a long time ago a long time
frankly before I got to office and I
think we're all to blame I think that
the United States now is stepped forward
along with Russia and we're getting
together and we have a chance to do some
great things whether it's nuclear
proliferation in terms of stopping have
to do it ultimately that's probably the
most important thing that we can be
working on but I do feel that we have
both made some mistakes I think that the
the probe is a disaster for our country
I think it's kept us apart
kept us separated there was no collusion
at all everybody knows it people are
being brought out to the fore so far
that I know virtually none of it related
to the campaign and they're gonna have
to try really hard to find somebody that
did relate to the campaign that was a
clean campaign I beat Hillary Clinton
easily and frankly we beat her and I'm
not even saying from the standpoint we
won that race and it's a shame that they
can even be a little bit of a cloud over
it people know that people understand it
but the main thing and we discussed this
also zero collusion and it has had a
negative impact upon the relationship of
the two largest nuclear powers in the
world we have 90 percent of nuclear
power between the two countries it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous what's going
on with the pro-president I could follow
up as well watch them Americans and why
should President Trump believe your
statement that Russia did not intervene
a 2016 election given the evidence that
US intelligence agencies have provided
and will you consider extraditing the 12
Russian officials that were indicted
last week by a US grand jury well I'm
going to let the president answer the
second part of that question but as you
know the whole concept of that came up
perhaps a little bit before but it came
out as a reason why the Democrats lost
an election which frankly they should
have been able to win because the
electoral college is much more
advantageous for Democrats as you know
than it is to Republicans we won the
electoral college by a lot 306 to 223 I
believe and that was a well-fought that
was a well-fought battle we did a great
job and frankly I'm gonna let the
president speak to the second part of
your question but just to say it one
time again and I say it all the time
there was no collusion I didn't know the
president there was nobody to collude
with there was no collusion with a
campaign and every time you hear all of
these
you know 12 and 14 it's stuff that has
nothing to do and frankly they admit
these are not people involved in the
campaign but to the average reader out
there they're saying well maybe that
does it doesn't and even the people
involved some perhaps told miss stories
although in one case the FBI said there
was no lie there was no life somebody
else said there was we ran a brilliant
campaign and that's why I'm president
thank you abbulu regarding who you
should believe and whether you can
believe anyone at all
you can't believe anyone but why do you
think but president Trump trusts me I
trust him defending the US interests I
defend the Russian interests we have
overlapping interests and we're looking
for common grounds we have things in
which we diverge so far and we're
looking for options to reconcile those
divergences how to make our constructive
we must base ourselves not on immediate
political interests in political forces
of our countries but on facts give me at
least one fact which would tell about a
certain collusion during the election
campaign in the United States it's
completely absurd we learned it from the
president and the fact that's in the
Russian society during the American
electoral campaign a certain opinion was
formed about specific candidates it's
quite normal what's so strange about it
President Trump as appended spoke about
the us-russian relations but that's
natural naturally created the sympathy
towards that kinda had seen the Russian
society and various people in expresses
sympathy are in various ways isn't it
natural to sympathize with somebody who
wants to build a relation with our
country
it's no more we heard our accusations
for about Concord as far as I know that
hired American home defenders American
lawyers and all those accusations
collapse in American courts that's the
things we should proper selves on not
rumors and the other thing concerning
those twelve alleged employees of our
secret services I happen to study that
question probably I still have to find
out but right now what I can say we
discussed and we discussed that in
general are the first thing that comes
to my mind we have an active agreement
between the United States and Russian
Federation 1999 the agreement on
cooperation in criminal cases that
agreement works in and works efficiently
to 100-150
in her inquiries per year and as the
appropriate number of criminal cases
that were open we had an extradition
last year when an American citizen was
extradited and engaged in the Russian
Court this agreement provides for
appropriate procedures we can propose
that all relevant Commission of views
headed by a prosecutor mr. millaa millaa
well as part of that agreement sends an
official request to us to conduct the
interrogation of those people who are
supposed to be guilty in various
offenses of prosecution services and
investigative bodies can conduct that
interrogation and forward the relevant
materials to the United States moreover
we can make one more step in the same
direction or we can allow
representatives of the United States
including their ahead mr. Miller allow
them to be present at those
interrogations but in that case we'll
certainly talk about making that action
mutual we would in that case expects the
American courts to interrogate those
officials including our officers of
special serve the intelligence services
which we suspect of conducting criminal
activities in the Russian Federation in
the presence of our investigators what
do I mean I mean the famous case of
Hermitage capital according to our
investigation a group of individuals and
business partners mr. Brown illegally
and over one and half billion dollars in
the Russian Federation without paying
taxes either in Russia or the United
States but they transferred that money
to the United States for hundred million
dollars where forward directed to the
electoral campaign of mrs. Clinton these
are official data they probably made
that legally but they earned their money
illegally so we have reasons to suppose
that certain officers intelligence
officers of the United States maintained
assisted illegally assisted her in those
transactions and that's just one example
where we can speak about broadening our
cooperation police suggest various
options various proposals they are made
possible by that agreement what
President Trump to win the election and
did you direct any of your officials to
help him do that I wanted him to win
because he spoke about normalization
over also American relations
do my own thing yeah we can have three
questions from the Russian pool rush
today you're welcome
spasibo Thank You Raj dobriy vecher good
evening my name is Lia patron because
all telecast Dimitri said our solution I
represent our tea channel in English mr.
president would you please go into the
details of possibly any specific
arrangements for the u.s. to work
together with Russia in Syria if any of
these kind of arrangements were made
today or discuss a question in Russian
as far as today a few towns will touch
upon the football subject I ask a
question on football language mr. Pompeo
slightly earlier said that when it was a
matter of interaction in Syria the ball
is on the Russian side fatima de mirage
is that really so and if that's so how
do you use that ball possession thank
you well I guess I'll answer the first
part of the question we've worked with
Israel long and hard for many years many
decades I think we've never never has
anyone and country been closer than we
are President Putin also is helping
Israel and we both spoke with Bibi
Netanyahu and they would like to do
certain things with respect to Syria
having to do with the safety of Israel
so in that respect we absolutely would
like to work in order to help Israel and
Israel will be working with us so both
countries would work jointly and I think
that when you look at all of the
progress that's been made in certain
sections with the eradication of Isis
about 98% 99% there and other things
that have taken place that we've done
and that frankly Russia has helped us
with in certain respects but I think
that they're working with
is a great thing and creating safety for
Israel is something that both President
Putin and I would like to see very much
one little thing I might add to that is
the helping of people helping of people
because you have such horrible if you
see and I've seen reports and I've seen
pictures I've seen just about everything
and if we can do something to help the
people of Syria get back into some form
of shelter and on a humanitarian basis
and that's what the word was really a
humanitarian basis I think that both of
us would be very interested in doing
that and we are we will do that thank
you very much excuse me but for now no
specific agreements for instance between
the militaries well our militaries do
get along fact our militaries actually
have gotten along probably better than
our political leaders for years but our
militaries do get along very well and
they do coordinate in Syria and other
places okay thank you
I mentioned cooperation the
communitarian humanitarian fields I just
yester discussed that with the president
of France mr. Makran and we agreed that
ourselves and the European countries are
going to activate that work we on our
part are prepared to provide transport
airplanes to carry those human
humanitarian cargo well we spoke about
that with mr. Trump this but what is
important there's a huge number refugees
concentrated in the neighboring states
Turkey Lebanon Jordan if we provide
assistance to people to help them return
home the migration and pressure on the
European Union countries other countries
or will diminish significantly I think
that's important from all points of view
humanitarian
in terms of solving the rgg problem but
as regards on the whole I agree with
with presidents our militaries cooperate
successfully I hope Lim will carry on a
green previously a will carry on working
in the in the Astana format with Turkey
and Iran are informed to Donald about
that and we are ready to combine those
efforts
with the efforts of the small group
so-called small group of states to have
the process acquire a broader nature and
to have the maximum chance for our final
success yes as regards the ball on our
part of the field in Syria mr. president
have spoken has spoken that we have
successfully just finished the World Cup
so as far as the ball is concerned I'm
passing the ball on to mr. president now
it's all right bullish goes to show even
did you go as the United States will
host C 2026 World Cup that's right thank
you very much we do host it and we hope
we do as good a job that's very nice
that will go to my son Baron we have no
question in fact Melania here you go
okay
the final question from the United
States will go to Jonathan O'Meara from
the AP
thank you a question for each president
president Trump you first just now
President Putin denied having anything
to do with the election air Ference in
2016 every US intelligence agency has
concluded that Russia did what who my
first question for you sir is who do you
believe my second question is would you
now with the whole world watching tell
President Putin would you denounce what
happened in 2016 and would you warn him
to never do it again so let me just say
that we have two thoughts you have
groups that are wondering why the FBI
never took the server
why haven't they taken the server why
was the FBI told to leave the office of
the Democratic National Committee I've
been wondering that up and asked you
that for months and months and I've been
tweeting it out and calling it out on
social media where is the server I want
to know where is the server and what is
the server saying with that being said
all I can do is ask the question my
people came to me dan coates came to me
and some others they said they think
it's Russia I have president putin he
just said it's not Russia I will say
this I don't see any reason why it would
be but I really do want to see the
server but I have I have confidence in
both parties I really believe that this
will probably go on for a while but I
don't think it can go on without finding
out what happened to the server what
happened to the servers of the Pakistani
gentleman that worked on the DNC where
are those servers they're missing where
are they what happened to Hillary
Clinton's emails 33,000 emails gone just
gone I think in Russia they wouldn't be
gone so easily I think it's a disgrace
that we can't get Hillary Clinton's
33,000 emails so I have great confidence
in my intelligence people but I will
tell you that President Putin was
extremely strong and powerful in his
denial today and what he did is it
incredible offer
he offered to have
the people working on the case come and
work with their investigators with
respect to the 12 people I think that's
an incredible offer okay thank you me as
a few words I also work to mean share
intelligence I know how to the
appropriate files are compiled just a
minute please
that's one thing the second is a
Democratic know that to your own country
the United States the United States is
it a democratic state in a crazy country
you that's so the final conclusion in a
dispute like that can be made only by
court by a court not by intelligence
services the company I managed Concord
and one of our restaurateurs
restaurateurs well are also facing
similar accusations but they don't
represent Russia they don't represent
the Russian state so what I've brought
some examples already you have many
people including with those those
multi-billion fortunes mr. Soros for
example who interferes everywhere but is
that the position of the American
government that's a private individual
it's the same here there is an
investigation there is a case in
American Court and the final decision is
only for the court let them make that
concerns only individuals specific
individuals not the government not the
state but the latest accusation well the
alleged cooperation of our intelligence
officers there is an agreement an
international agreement bilateral
agreement let your commission send a
query will act on it and send your reply
we can enlarge that corporation but only
on a mutual basis in that case we'll be
also expecting access provided by the
American party for us to those
individuals we think our intelligence
agents let's discuss it properly let's
not use the American Russian relations
as a currency as a trump card
in the political fight for you sir
can you tell me what President Trump may
have indicated to you about officially
recognizing Crimea as part of Russia and
then secondly sir do you does the
Russian government have any compromising
material on President Trump or his
family
and [ __ ] well prices might run position
on Crimea is known he adheres to it he
says that it was illegal the annexation
of the Crimea to the Russian Federation
we have a different point of view we
think we conducted the referendum in
strict accordance with the international
law and see a United Nations Charter you
know that question is closed for us for
Russians as regarding the compromising
materials I've heard that we've
allegedly been collecting those
materials on mr. Trump when he was
coming to Moscow dear colleagues when
mr. Trump was coming to Moscow didn't
even know he was there I treat mr. Trump
with respect as the head of the American
state but when he came over as a
businessman I didn't even know he was in
Moscow st. Petersburg Economic Forum in
st. Petersburg it was attended by over
500 American businessman Oh very high
rank
I don't even know their name sir won't
remember the names of most of them do
you think we're going to collect
evidence on all of them
bollocks you can't even imagine a great
nonsense oh please
throw that asks throw that rubbish out
of your head long ago and if anybody
watched Peter struck testify over the
last couple of days and I was in
Brussels watching it it was a disgrace
to the FBI it was a disgrace to our
country and you wouldn't say that was a
total witch hunt thank you very much
everybody thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
and with that's the Trump Putin summit
in Helsinki has concluded not too many
questions taken by both of the
presidents there but the liberal feeling
of what went on in some expressed by
Donald Trump
you may remember us reporting that
before it took place Donald Trump had
tweeted at relations between the United
States and Russia with the worst level
ever well he came in to that news
conference and repeated that but say it
said that changed four hours ago I also
referred to the talks has been direct
open deeply productive talks on his part
President Putin of Russia said again
similar kind of sentiments that there
were many problems remaining between
them but this was the first step in
building a good working atmosphere you
could again tell by the body language
between the two men that which there
were must have been many many
disagreements probably more
disagreements than agreements and we'll
be examining those during the course of
the afternoon in particular in actual
fact that last question that was put to
President Putin in a very direct answer
from Vladimir Putin on the issue of
Crimea he said he understands the
Americans position on the annexation of
Crimea that it was in effect illegal but
President Putin said he felt that so
they carried out a referendum there to
allow to join the Russian Federation in
accordance with UN rules and there would
be no compromise he said on Crimea the
other big issue arising was of course
that hanging over this entire summit the
issue of meddling in American politics
the issue of meddling in the election of
2016 now President Trump said on that
that Vladimir Putin has quote-unquote an
interesting idea
about who's behind that interference now
he didn't expand on that point it would
have been interesting perhaps if one of
the the journalists had drilled down a
bit more on that
but Mr Trumper stayed with again what he
tweeted the
or this summit I hold both countries ie
the United States and Russia responsible
for poor relations we are all to blame
and by that he means the previous
Democrats administration when it comes
to the American side